so you know I have to ask you right  you're your favorite on-screen kiss who  is the best like if you could go back  see a scene and still get the  butterflies  oh God why is this plaguing me have you  ever seen any of your movies they're  really good you should watch them I know  I'm like I'm so lucky I got to because  Matthew McConaughey Edward Norton Adam  Sandler Hugh Grant Ben Stiller oh my God  you're living my diary is what you're  living my dear diary I Luke Wilson Oh  God who else I've gotten so lucky at all  the boys I've gotten to kiss for work I  don't know if anyone else is talking  about this but it's so mechanical and  the second you even if you can get into  it they like y'all cut or they're like  it's not in the right position it's a  weird thing to kiss someone in like this  more professional setting so you never  really not as sexy as you would think